okay so there's a question about
watching the movie boy who harnessed the
wind which I've not watched kids
wondering how windmills actually work
and generate energy okay all right good
question okay let's see what the easiest
way to explain this is so what's kind of
happening in a windmill is the reverse
of what's happening in an electric car
so an electric car what you're doing is
you're turning electrical and turning
energy from a battery electrical energy
into mechanical motion turning the
wheels of the car around and it just so
happens the wave physics are set up most
effects like that if you can go from
electricity to motion it turns out it's
sort of a basic fact of physics that you
can reverse things like that and you can
say let's go from motion to electricity
and that's essentially what's happening
in a windmill is that you're running
kind of electric motor in Reverse the
wind is is turning the sails of the the
blades of the windmill and and that's
that's running the it's kind of like
running the electric car in Reverse to
go from from mechanical motion to
electrical energy now if you ask how
does that how does the windmill work why
does the weight of the blades of the
windmill turn around they actually turn
around for they're kind of doing the
reverse of what the propeller of an
airplane would do so the propeller of an
airplane each each each propeller blade
is shaped so that it will try and push
air from the engine of the plane as
making the propeller go around and the
propeller blade is shaped so that it
will push air backwards and when they
when the air is pushed backwards that
will cause the airplane to go forwards
that's a another one of these sort of
physics principles that if you sort of
push momentum backwards it will make you
go forwards so the the so sort of the
idea is that the windmill is kind of
like the propeller of a plane working
backwards and
case the wind is blowing across the
propeller which is causing or the the
the blades of the windmill causing them
to turn and then that's causing the sort
of reverse electric car to work and
making energy now if you ask me why why
is it the case that when you how does it
actually work to get electric how does
an electric motor work for example okay
that's a little bit tricky it's a little
tricky and it has to do with features
about magnetism and electricity let me
let me I I would be if people are
interested I can try and tackle that one
that's a little bit non-trivial because
it term I mean I can just sort of tell
you facts about how electricity and
magnetism work but it's more fun if one
can explain why those facts are true and
there's a bit of a stack of physics that
you have to explain to explain why those
things are true it all has to do with a
thing called electromagnetic induction
which is a phenomenon that um well okay
so people know about magnets right
you've seen magnets how the magnets work
well magnets are typical magnet is made
of iron and what happens is inside so so
a magnet works gosh we have to go a
couple of levels here the magnet works
because each little iron atom inside the
magnet is acting like its own little
tiny magnet but the question is how do
those things act like tiny magnets how
do you get how do you get a magnetic
field magnetism from anything else but
it turns out that when you have an
electric current when you have
electricity flowing electricity flowing
produces a magnetic field and what is
electricity electricity is a flow of
electrons so electrons are these little
tiny particles that exist in every atom
but in a in a metal and which is like a
thing like a wire that conducts
electricity it turns out that some of
the the electrons usually electrons are
stuck inside atoms there's a nucleus of
atoms with protons
neutrons there's all sort of electrons
going around outside the nucleus and
usually the electrons are just sort of
stuck inside the atom but in a metal
something special happens their end up
being electrons that are not stuck
inside atoms their end up being
electrons that are delocalized that can
sort of move through the metal and so
when you have an electric current what's
happening is that electrons these
delocalized electrons are able to move
through the metal and that's and the
electrons each electron carries a little
tiny amount of electric charge and as
those electrons move through the metal
they are producing an electric current
and one of the facts about physics is
that when you have an electric current
and you have a moving electron it
produces a magnetic field so one of the
things that you can do is you can have
electrons that are moving in a circle
you can have a electric current that's
just going around in a circle so there
are these things called solenoids which
are just sort of loops of wire that are
turned around many times a a solenoid
with a bunch of loops of wire the
electrons are just going around and
around and round these loops of wire and
they're producing a magnetic field and
the way it works it's a little bit
complicated the the magnetic field is at
right angles to the direction of the of
the motion of the electrons and so when
you think through the geometry it means
that in this loop of wire there's a
magnetic field that is pointing right
out of the loop of wire so the loops
going around this way
the magnetic field is pointing that way
so when you what's actually happening
inside the iron is roughly roughly
roughly roughly I'm cheating a little
bit but roughly the electrons inside the
iron atom they're kind of going round
their nuclei and they're kind of being
like tiny versions of those loops of
wire those electrons going around loops
of wire and they're making income making
a magnetic field and that's what the
individual little magnets that make up
the magnetic fields from a block of iron
that's what they come from okay so given
this fact that a an electron that's
moving produces a magnetic field it and
another fact is that a magnetic field
makes an electron move when you sort of
combine those facts together
and use a bit of kind of engineering
cleverness you can make that turn into
her electric motor works